hello everyone if you've seen my
previous video fish were finally got his
first win against Michael Tao in the
super tournament in bled in 1961 and
although Fischer didn't win this
tournament
Michael towel was I think one point
ahead of him so tal won this tournament
a Fisher was already planning on here's
a great match with Botvinnik and he was
already thinking about where the match
should take place little did he know
that his match for the World
Championship was 10 years ahead of this
moment and it was won't be against
bottom unique it will be against the
boris spassky and reykjavik but this is
a game played one year after this
encounter and this was played in 1962 in
Stockholm and the Michael Todd wasn't
playing this tournament so this was a
great opportunity for Bobby Fischer to
finally win
a very strong tournament but although
Tala wasn't playing here there were a
very a couple of very strong Soviet
grandmasters here like a singular
different petrosyan and the younger
Russian superstar Viktor Korchnoi and
well the greatest round of this
tournament was definitely Fisher versus
Petrosyan where Fischer was upon up but
Petrosyan managed to draw the game but
the next best thing here would be
definitely the game fish were against
Viktor Korchnoi so that's the game of
about to show you Bobby Fischer is white
and the Viktor Korchnoi is black and
yeah I have to mention that Bobby is
still into collecting suits and he
bought four new suits and one new very
elegant suit for this occasion and a
pair of new shoes so he is not only
interested in winning the tournament he
is also interested to be the most
elegant Grandmaster there so Bobby goes
efore he 5 9 f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to
b5 a6
the standard elope is more fee defense
Bishop to a4 Knight to f6
Fischer castles Bishop to e7 rook to e1
b5 Bishop to b3 Coronet castles c3 d6 d4
Bishop to g4 Bishop to e3
he takes d4 C takes d4 and that
Fisher retrieves the Bishop Bishop to c2
and at the c-4 they should see one
and now c5 that's the whole point of
night moving from c6 to get this Queen
side expansion even though this night
wasn't it's not isn't gonna be on c4 for
a very long time so Fisher kicks them
out B 3 9 2 8 5 d 5 9 3 7 9 2 d2 Bishop
to f6 we're up to be 1 and getting the
rock out of the way
c4 h3 captures captures and now C takes
on b3 8x + b3 Queen to c7 Bishop to e3
and I'll Bishop to c3 rock to e2 and now
before and here it seems like Korchnoi
may have accomplished something on the
Queen side locking the position like
this but you'll see in a couple of very
subtle moves how Fischer handles the
position Fischer plays Knight to d4 and
of course this night is very dangerous
here as black's knight is on a5 not
really doing anything if he ever moves
to b7 Fischer has this nice c6 square
and you definitely don't want to capture
the night with the bishop because well
you don't want to give Fischer a bishop
pair so question it goes rook F to e8
Knight to f5 Knight to be 7 bishop to d4
and again capturing on d4 and Queen
takes d4 would be very annoying for
black here as its eyeing the g7 pawn so
quarter goes g6 allowing this night to
h6 check came to f8 and now rook the c1
and here again you'll see in a couple of
very subtle moves have Fisher gets from
this position to a very dominant
position so rook to see one eyeing this
Queen and c7 and fortunately doubles up
rope to c8 and here Fischer plays Bishop
to d3 attacking this a6 pawn but this
also makes room for this other Brooke I
need you to go to c2 so fortunately
defends the pawn Queen to a5 and now
rook to c2 and now Fischer is the master
this c-file course my place Knight to e5
Bishop to f1 and now Knight to c5 and
this night to c5 move as you can see a
coroner doesn't really have a good move
to play here this Bishop cannot move
because the rook is pinned the Queen
cannot move as it has the gardius ace
exponent from the bishop on f1 he you
can't capture because again this rope is
pinned and this net has nowhere to go so
the only thing cautionary could come up
with is to give up a pawn to maybe get
some activity so he plays Knight to c5
and Fisher happily takes the pawn bishop
takes and c3b takes in c3 and rook takes
on c3 and here fish raised up a pawn
king to g7 attacking the knight Knight
to g4 Knight captures energy for Queen
captions on the g4 and our rook to b8
this replace the roof to f3 94 Queen to
f4 attacking that f7 pawn coarsening
goes f5 rook to e3 rook the e5 and here
rook to c6 this is a this is a very
dangerous move as it is threatening rook
takes on d6 because after drug takes
then this rook is undefended and course
my place rook to e8 which is a which is
an essential move because if course
might play something like I don't know
rook to e8 or something then this before
move is very unpleasant for black the
Queen cannot stand this diagonal so the
Queen well there's no other move really
but to capture the pawn and then route
the c7 check is coming and after it came
to any move like okay not f8 but maybe
King to g8 and queen to h6 and well
checkmate is unstoppable
so here course my place rook to e8
so now roof to c7 check isn't really
that dangerous as the route can cover up
so Fisher captures rook to d6 his
original threat Queen to a-1
rope captures on a six Queen to d4 rope
to d3 attacking the Queen Queen B to D 6
g 5 23 F 4 and now Quint a7 check and
well here cautionary resigns after a
move like maybe King to g8 then d7 is
coming and well this is deadly you have
to block the pawn somehow maybe rope to
d8 and then Queen to c7 with a double
attack on both rooks this is well
trashing for white and Fischer did win
this game and he easily won the
tournament two whole rounds before the
tournament ended Fischer had first place
didn't really matter if he lost the last
two rounds so this is Bobby's first win
in a really big international event and
although Michael tall wasn't playing
there it was still a pretty big pretty
big victory so yeah that's the game
that's I think this is the first
encounter between Fischer and young
Viktor Korchnoi will in 1974 be playing
the candidates to challenge Fischer for
the World Championship although he will
lose the Karpov but okay yeah I hope you
enjoyed it and if you're interested
here are my two previous videos you can
check those out and yeah see you soon
[Music]